film courage women
and caring
talk with you
I had this epiphany that I was on set on
a video and I i was listening to Led
Zeppelin and I was doing a hip-hop song
so I thought there was something wrong
there I was blasting Zeppelin and I'm
doing this like this really big
commercial hip-hop song and I thought to
myself I think we were in Florida or New
York i thought when i go back to LA I'm
gonna bring what I know about lighting
into the field of what I'm doing kind of
documentary photography and I'm gonna
give this a shot and I'm going to get
back on the path to making a movie so I
was going to do a fade out of music
video and a push into stills and also
develop film at the time so that was the
plan and um photo I always say is a
pleasant accident because it was and
people always kind of go earlier
photographer and you know I met
photography 11 years ago it's the newest
thing that i did and i found it to be a
less forceful journey in a more creative
outlet because at the time music videos
got bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and at the height it was very
influenced by management and product
placement and it wasn't the same game we
used to be able to write something
insane on a piece of paper and go
directed